any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
welcome everybody to this episode of the
into the impossible podcast a production
of the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination at UC san diego
I am your fearful host Brian Keating
co-director of the arthur c clarke
center for human imagination a professor
of physics at UC san diego and today's
very special day because don't often get
to interview people that have known me
since before I was born and people who
have played such a huge role in my life
in particular but in literally you know
millions of people around the world's
lives and that's none other than Jim
Simon's dr. Jim Simon's who is joining
us from New York where he has been
sheltering I presume for quite some time
Jim welcome to the into the impossible
podcast
well thanks glad to be here so this
podcast is really a discussion of ideas
with great intellectuals and thinkers
and I always like to get to know people
a little bit better usually I ask
questions about their books or or so
forth but what I want to start off with
you is to kind of ask you if you know
somebody an alien abducted you and could
speak English to you and ask you who are
you how would you answer that question
what defines Jim Simon's to you Who am I
and what how do i define myself yeah
scientist hmm well I've been three
things I've been a mathematician I have
run an investment fund and now a
foundation foundation it focuses on
basic science of all strikes so I've
done three three things in my life aside
from having a couple of children etc and
well that's that's been my life someone
wrote a book about me this past year and
I didn't even want him to do it but it
didn't come out too badly so you can
learn about be somewhat in that book
yeah we had Greg Greg Zuckerman he was a
guest on the podcast a few months back
so yes we did talk about that book and
you know but I've always encouraged you
to write a book and Mary to know what my
daughter keeps urging me to to do so I'm
gonna retire soon from the foundation
and then have more time to write my
memoirs or something like that but I
don't know what else I can tell you to
describe myself I think I imagine a tip
I think I have a lot of imagination and
I've had my share of good ideas bad ones
sometimes of course the fact when you're
doing science probably have five bad
ideas for every good one but my friend
Lenny Baum said he said bad ideas is
good good ideas is better no ideas is
terrible and when you're doing signs you
have a lot of bad ideas but you know but
you get some good ones if you're a good
scientist and those carry the day now
that's great and I like to think about
you yes as a ponderer as an intellectual
and I I guess I I for most think of you
as a scientist because even in
philanthropy and even in your role as a
department chair and in your roles
throughout throughout the you know the
financial world
you've always adopted it seems to me a
scientist mentality where you approach
things just as he said I could replace
what you said ideas with experiments and
you do many many experiments thought
experiments and some succeed succeed and
some are actual experiments in real life
I'm not just talking about the Simon's
Observatory but I'm talking about
running you know running projects and
part of what I wanted to talk to you
about today is this notion of leadership
in these different communities and these
different hats that you've worn and
whether or not you think there's some
translation or some skill set that you
had uniquely that made you a good leader
of these industries or professions
because people are lucky enough to have
one career let alone three and I wonder
you know were you just born with it was
there something that was instilled in
you by your parents or your upbringing
you're relatively modest upbringing and
outside of Boston is there anything that
instilled that or is it just your nature
that you were kind of born this way well
we're talking about leadership well I
have a lot of imagination so I've come
up with some ideas that have worked but
my idea of leadership of an organization
is to hire the very best people you
possibly can and I have a good taste in
people mm-hmm and then let them carry
the ball hmm and when I became chair of
the Stony Brook math department I
reached out for the best person I could
possibly find and he was your father
and I knew if your dad would come on
board it would open up the floodgates of
people saying oh well this department
can really go somewhere so I spent a lot
of time courting your father and finally
he said yes and then I was able to
quickly hire three or four other
outstanding people and and we did that
over the next couple of years I hired
ten people the first year ten to second
and I think maybe ten people the third
year and by then we built up an
outstanding the park that's kind of
certainly it's very touching for you to
speak about my father James acts in that
way and and I know that you know you had
always been described to me by my mother
and and even by my dad is having this
preternatural ability to recognize
talent and to but not only to like be
the the chess player needs to know not
only the names of the pieces and to that
it's better to have a lot of you know
Queens than a lot of pawns but but
actually how to implement them how to
recruit them into action and get them to
do you know some of the work that that
is needed to be done for success on a
project you once told me that you read a
fiction book called the captain or
something like that that was very
influential on you as a leader can you
remind me the name of that book because
I have not been able to find it yet it
was when I was about to become chair of
Stony Brook I was 30 years old and and I
found this book I think it might have
been called captain about a young fellow
in the Navy who became captain of a boat
party young age and kind of learned how
to be a commander and and one of the
things he learned is don't Donald too
much about making a decision make a
decision it may be wrong but it's better
to make a decision than just Donald and
Donald and make no decision and that
seems like an important lesson to me and
I've always been reasonably decisive I
can solve with other people and so on
there's one should but I don't you know
just go back and forth and back and
forth for a long time I make the
decision hmm sometimes it's wrong
but most of the time my decision Shepard
good another lesson I learned from you a
little while ago was you know when
people have something really important
to them say in a department when you
were chair at Stony Brook you would let
them debate it maybe it wasn't at the
top number one or two priority in your
mind
but you could tell it was important to
them and you let them discuss it and
instead of weighing in on every single
decision that you'd let people to whom
it made the most you know impact on make
those decisions and then when you would
sit those out or you know kind of just
share the meeting so to speak and then
by the you know for the for the meetings
that had something of great importance
to you personally then you would weigh
in and you would have more gravitas is
that something that you learned on the
job or that how did you you know come to
that realization that that was an
effective management technique well you
did describe that exactly as it was so
here's how it was yeah I learned quickly
that when you have a department leave
there were a lot of opinions people like
to argue go back and forth on this and
that and and so I determined that okay
people like to debate fine on that
elective debate but if it's something
important I'll make the decision in the
first place announce that we're going to
do this or we're going to do that and as
the you know maybe the first item on the
agenda of a department movie and then I
was very happy to let everyone debate
other other things that were coming up
which I didn't think was so important so
okay fine this way that way we come to
with the closure but if it was really
important I would just announce it
myself he no one objected so that was
the way I ran Department released
when when you you know had the
opportunity to play a role in these
different three different fields
you know philanthropy finance and
academia do you feel that there are
commonalities maybe the point I'm
getting at mostly is I think there's not
we never received training here's how
you should be a department chair you
know there doesn't seem to be a lot of
you know mentorship or guidance it's
kind of like sink or swim you're thrown
into this job and you either perform or
you don't and even when you perform you
might be victim of the Peter Principle
you know you rise to the level of your
incompetence as it said but you know do
you you think that that's something
that's missing in academia at least in
science maybe even in philanthropy how
do we cultivate the next generation of
leaders well that's a good question it's
it's interesting than math departments
unless there's a lot of money available
and you can really build up the
department substantially most people
don't necessarily want the job as
department chair it's often saying okay
it's my turn I'll do it for three years
up or four years but I don't know you
know I want to do research teaching I'm
not so interested in administration now
in other fields
that's not the case in biology or
medical school the chair of the
department that's really and it's not
only an important thing but a
sought-after State yes when I was
interviewing for chair of the math
department the what the provost he said
something very funny he said well dr.
Simon you know the first person I've
interviewed for this job who actually
wants it no I they
so I don't know if there's I think
people who rise up in academia get the
experience they see you know what other
people are doing even what the stakes
they may have made or whatever and try
to learn and I think that's the way
people rise up in any organization so do
you see it as a I don't know secret to
it right I mean I just can't imagine
somebody being offered you know CEO or
managing director of Renaissance
Technologies
I'm not sure I got to think about it why
do you think it is that people you know
it's almost like a you know the booby
prize in academia if you're selected for
department chair it's like
congratulations question mark or my
condolences but but it really should be
you know somebody offered somebody the
CEO of Apple I don't think they saw I
really got to think about this I got to
talk to my you know my spouse well I
mean it's a different deal
it takes you being the department chair
at least in in mathematics and perhaps
physics or astronomy as it takes you
away from your research mm-hmm and your
research is the thing most people want
to do the most yeah so they feel okay I
have to do some administration it's my
turn I'll do the best I can but I'll be
glad when it's over so whereas you know
running a company as a whole is a
hold-up ordeal mm-hmm that's something
that some people are good at and really
want to do that and lead the company and
make a lot of money you know uh academic
departments don't make a lot of money
yeah
that's the way I see it last year we
were together for the total solar
eclipse in Chile and I asked you you
know if you could arrange a dinner party
for a famous single person from history
you know a hundred years or more ago who
would it be and you basically
instantaneously said Abraham link
and I wonder what does he mean to you
and and are there lessons in his
leadership style that that speak to you
so loudly that he would be the
historical figure that you'd most like
to sit down with for for a meal yeah
well I only really have one hero in my
life and it anat Abraham Lincoln there's
a many people I admire and so on but as
a hero disable him Lincoln and he had
the following qualities he had very very
good social skills people like to be
around and he told a lot of jokes and so
on he was very smart he was very smart
then his middle before he became
president he decided to study Euclidian
geometry and understand that much
mathematics just not his own but he was
just curious and he was a very very
smart guy good social skills wonderful
social skills and determination he had
determination there were so many times
during the Civil War where he could have
just said to help let's just have two
countries so many people are being
killed in this terrible war but he had a
vision of America and he stuck to that
vision and and just wouldn't give up and
over time he was right and that held the
country together we won the Civil War I
said we won the Civil War the North if
the North won and and then he got what
great effort the amendment passed which
abolished slavery in the United States
and that was very difficult to get past
but he knew he had a had to get it
passed before the wall was over and
there were a lot of southerners when I
back in the Congress said it would
wouldn't get passed and he said to his
guys he said this is very important I
want you to go out and do everything you
can twist every arm give people that saw
that if they if they feel they need it
I'm the president of the United States
I'm confused with great power use that
power and get this amendment passed and
it worked so I think it was just just a
great minute in every respect if I'm not
mistaken the poem Oh captain my captain
which has the title captain from your
book that he mentioned earlier is
written about Abraham Lincoln speaking
of books and Abraham Lincoln is there
any book any book a biography of Lincoln
that you recommend or story about him by
any author which ones do you like if I
can't remember any of the names I'm
terrible at name called team of rivals
that by Doris Kearns Goodwin that's well
that's right that's in the Bible that's
the most recent interesting semi
biography of him because it was about
the other people are his cabinet but but
that was an example these people have
wanted to be president they've got at
least a couple of them and and he said
look you know you're the best guys
around I want you on my cabinet and they
came and at a certain point not too late
in the game
Stanton became the Secretary of War they
called the Secretary of War replacing a
poor choice that he had made for that
so that guy left in Staunton came in and
got to know Lincoln now he had met
Lincoln years earlier Lincoln was a
railroad lawyer and he did a very good
job in the Midwest representing grille
and really just coming into the United
States and there were you know legal
issues and trials and so on so he was a
very good railroad lawyer but there was
a big case with a big road and and it
was gonna be held in Cincinnati he was
put on it but then the railroad said
well we really need a big New York firm
we really need to put a lot of heft into
this so they hired Stanton and his firms
Lincoln Lincoln was still on the job but
he just asked Erin listen and later said
you know I learned a lot from her
but Stanton and his team that they just
thought this guy was a dope you know he
just sat there he didn't say anything
whatever and later when he became in
Lincoln's cabinet and understood Lincoln
was he was quoted as saying none was so
wrong than we in Cincinnati know that's
what led to the trial was held so
Stanton told his cabinet you know really
was adored him or marked by the adored
of this room strong Ward sounds too
lovey-dovey
but admired and he was just a great man
I could go on I'm sure I want to touch
upon what you mentioned before and we
had this conversation also in the
Declaration of Independence Thomas
Jefferson declares certain things is
self-evident and Steven Strogatz who
hosts the quanta magazine joy of X
podcast for quanta magazine which is a
at least sponsored by the Simons found a
the Stephen points out that that very
phrase you know we hold these truths to
be self-evident is really a reference to
Euclidean geometry where Euclid would
prove things in his elements which is
one of your favorite books I know and
and he would say such and such is
self-evident
and I wonder if we could segue into a
little bit of a discussion about why
math appeals to you and has from a young
age because if I recall correctly one of
your first you know realizations and
encounters with math was sort of a
realization of what we call Zeno's
paradox and I wondered can you recount
the story of when you basically at age
what four or five really kind of
rediscovered or discovered Zeno's
paradox for yourself and what did that
do igniting within you and perhaps a
love of mathematics well let's let's go
back into Euclid but he said was
self-evident were the axiom the neural
Azzam axiom that was the toughest one
two points to describe a unique line and
and the intersection principle so those
he said were self-evident but from then
on the terms that developed from these
were not self-evident they were all
while some of the obvious but
nonetheless they were all proved using
these initial quote-unquote self-evident
things now my discovery of Zeno's
paradox was when I was a little boy
maybe three or four I was riding in the
car with my father and he said he had a
stop to get gas I said well why why do
you think that he's I don't want to run
out of gas because you know the
Commonwealth won and I said well why
don't you just use half the amount
that's in the tank and then use half of
that and then use half of that etc and
you'll never run out
again know it I didn't think it further
through would realize yes but you'll
never get anywhere but but I could see
that you know you just keep cutting
something down it happened this feels
something left so that was something
that I also when I was a little boy
well my kid did this I think just kept
doubling numbers 1 2 4 8 16 I got up
2024 I suppose before I got bored with
it I thought that was that was fun but
one thing I used to think a lot hmm I
would think a lot and sometimes talk to
myself and when I went to bed and for
some reason or another and I couldn't
have been more than 10 I've heard the
expression pass it on and I know you
know you know what that means
pass it on but I lay in bed and said
well how do you define that
if I say so-and-so has got to be married
pass it on for example well you say tell
the next guy and tell him to tell the
next guy and tell him to tell the next
guy etc recursively yeah yeah to get a
definition and I tossed and turned for
several days trying to get a definition
of pass it on
finally one night honestly believing I
had it but when I woke up I forgot what
I had the night before so I finally just
said the hell
and but but the little kid would think
about the question of how you define
something you know unusual yeah that's
that's impressive for sure and and do
you feel that that I always see with my
little kids when they solve a puzzle a
jigsaw puzzle or crossword puzzle like
Marilyn you know must have instilled in
me as a young person and now my kids
play cross do crossword puzzles on their
iPhones and iPads when they solve it
they almost want to redo it because they
get a little taste of excitement that
mirrors and mimics the excitement that
they felt when they saw that the first
time and I wonder if that encounter that
math encounter that you that you
underwent at that young age do you think
that was an incisive event that had an
impact on your later development you
know into becoming a mathematician later
on in life well I don't know it's that
particular thing that way of thinking
that that way of curiosity that you had
yes I think that's that's probably true
that was a something that I never forgot
actually mathematics was the only
subject that I liked actually been
grammar school and even in high school I
didn't like science was not very well
taught and I didn't I was a voracious
reader so I loved literature but I
didn't write very well so but the
subject that that I loved was
mathematics and in those days when I was
in high school the AP thing was just
coming into play right so and a few high
schools had been chosen to pioneer this
thing and my high school Newton High
School in Massachusetts was one of them
so I learned calculus
in high school which today you know
first-year calculus which today the AP
courses take that wasn't called ap it
was called a the something plan but
whatever it was Kenyon plan was called
the Kenyan plan I don't know why but uh
so so I took a bad advanced course in
them and then went to MIT and I learned
later that the but got might my teacher
in the in the twelfth grade was one of
the people who designed the test and
then you know consulted with others who
passed the test a little bit and someone
told me he said Simon's has to pass the
test if if he can't that could be a
level Aoife passed the test so his floor
should be a passing score that was the
standard that would break up so and so I
anyway I went to college and studied
math in my freshman year I took a
graduate course in the second semester
and it said know what you call it no you
didn't have to have taken any other
course no prerequisites no prerequisite
no prerequisite so I said okay to myself
I'm going to take this course so that
was fun abstract algebra good theory and
some vector spaces and so on and I was
very puzzled by this course I passed it
but I really didn't understand
what it was all about hmm but that
summer I got a book on algebra and
within a couple of weeks I realized oh
that's why it's all about I just had
this over the summer this vision
Tiffany I missed epiphany mm-hmm that
this is what this is all about and from
then on the next two years I took the
most advanced algebra classes and in my
third year it was with a guy named in
with shower and it was topics in algebra
was called and I think I was the only
person in the class was a was a graduate
class and I was in my third year and I
think I was the only one who solved all
the problems and that was the homework
so so I was good at algebra but my I was
also introduced to differential geometry
in that same year and I loved it I just
loved it and felt that I would do very
well with that which which I did I when
I learned Stokes theorem I thought that
was the most beautiful theorem I ever
saw
Stokes it generalizes the fundamental
theorem of calculus that you know it's
just that the virgin's theorem showing
all wrapped up in Stokes theorem and
this notion of differential forms you
know that differential form is yeah of
course we're gonna talk about that next
yeah go ahead describe it for my
listeners though the differential form
and why it's so beautiful as you say so
we we talked about the you know kind of
relationship it's almost you know
mirroring I believe what Hilbert said
the unreasonable effectiveness of
mathematics in a vague nurse re big nur
it's almost there's a second order
unreasonable effectiveness of geometry
and physics and we talk about our
connection between geometric forms and
and their utility in geometry general
relativity and more recently in in terms
of quantum field theory and
understanding the properties of of you
know at the the the behavior particles
in these abstract spaces and lately
there's been a lot of controversy
there's a young well I shouldn't say
young he's a couple years older than me
and I'm not young but there's a man by
the name of Eric Weinstein who I believe
you know and he's he's trying to develop
what he calls a really a geometric
theory of all of physics and is very
controversial but effectively finding
the analogs of particles that we call
fermions in an abstract fourteen
dimensional geometric space and these
connections one forms two forms metric
connections these are vital attributes
of of this model that he's constructed
and it's and some of its in analogy with
with work that's that's already been
done and what what he what Eric this
Eric Winston has done is he's made a
digital version of your of the famous
Simon Center for geometry and physics
has what's called the iconic wall of
mathematics and physics and no on this
on this huge wall 465 square foot wall
are the basic and I'm gonna have a link
and I'll show images in the video of
this conversation
you have the metric equation of Einstein
equations which are you know two forms
geometric objects and differential
geometry and some claim that this is the
pinnacle not only of math and physics
but really of civilization that the art
that the equations on your wall
represent the pinnacle of what we've
been able to achieve as a species and
you said something interesting a few
minutes ago you said when you understood
Stokes theorem it it was beautiful to
you and I want to connect that to the
Simon Center the wall do you think of
math as beautiful in the sense that art
is beautiful
I mean we often hear this debate you
know as mathematics discovered or
invented I don't think people would say
Michelangelo discovered you know the
David inside of a block of marble even
though he would say stuff like that but
he actually created it but mathematics
and what's chiseled into your wall in
the Simon Center do you feel that that's
you know discovered or really is it
invented by the human mind and then the
follow-up question after you answer that
will be is it beautiful is it does it
rank amongst alongside great music great
artwork and if so why so first is
mathematics discovered or invented the
way art or the you know inventions are
discard that's a standard question yeah
and it's it's both hmm how's the brief
every true theorem is out there the
number of true theorems is I believe
infinite and the number of definitions
that one can make is infinite hmm so all
these things are out there but on the
other hand you don't know this there's
no book of all these things because it's
an infinite number of possible theorems
and definition ideas in doing
mathematics to what they find a good
definition a definition that will get
you somewhere a definition that would
unify perhaps other things and so on so
that's a creative act so it's a creative
act to find something interesting in an
infinite field and in an infinite
collection of things so it's out there
but you have to find it and have good
taste in finding something that will
really go somewhere hmm so it's guided
by wisdom as well
knowledge I think that's that's
interesting and then the question the
follow-up question is is math a form of
art does it have commonalities is it
different than music or art does it move
you I've always been curious does it do
you feel does it invoke any emotions
when you look at the wall not just for
its artistic beauty which it is but when
you see the author on a foam effect or
you see you know the Dirac equation or
just a pure mathematical a relationship
Stokes Stokes theorem when you see these
does it evoke an emotion inside of Jim
Simons well I mean I've seen these
things so often it's hard to keep
getting emotional I know yeah but the
notion of is math bakit of to you are
you an emotional person first of all and
then you know does math evoke great
beauty the way that great art or music
doesn't some people well Matt certainly
evokes beauty it's when someone does
something or whatever it's it's very
often it's characterized all that's a
beautiful theorem and that that's a
beautiful result the beauty is permeates
mathematics so I think there's an
aesthetic to it that that's why we use
that word hmm and of course our regular
artists can be beautiful and poems can
be beautiful and all those things but
mathematics definitely is characterized
by beauty excellent so the next question
I have is just kind of a yes or no
question don't feel obliged to elaborate
too much there's a there's an often said
you know canard or what have you quipped
that mathematicians peak at age 30
that's the age that you started the math
department at Stonybrook do you find any
credence and that my father didn't think
it was true but that what's your opinion
about this notion that all
mathematicians do their best work by age
30 mathematicians can do a lot of good
work by age 30 but they can do a lot of
good work
at age 50 or 60 I've reached a point 82
where I really can't do math anymore but
I could up to my early 70s so I got some
good results actually when I went back
to mathematics for one so I think yes
young people can do terrific things but
the older people can do good stuff too I
don't think it's everyone every
mathematician did his best work when he
was under 30 that's probably not the
case okay now we're gonna transition a
little bit into a later career which was
involving in the financial world but
we're gonna connect it to a famous
geometers
in physics and that's Albert Einstein
so our segue between geometry and
finance will be none other than Albert
Einstein who once said that compound
interest is the most powerful force in
the universe
compound interest is the eighth wonder
of the world he who understands it earns
it he who doesn't pays it do you agree
with this okay I'll send you I'll send
you an email with the quarter yeah so
once again compound interest is the
eighth wonder of the world
he who understands it earns it and he
who doesn't pays it
what is your notion of the what's the
most powerful force in the world
according to Jim Simon's going to me is
some physical force I don't know which
one to think but but this of course is
finance finance and not enough physic so
d I've been pretty successful in finance
you've had some success I would say you
know today actually I lost some money no
no not a huge I'm here for you Jim if
you if you need anything I was but yeah
how do you how do you think of yourself
so this segues into something that I
think will be of great interest not
because your of your total mass amassed
wealth or anything but how do you think
of money what is money to you is it is
it a tool is it as a device some people
see money in a very negative way
nowadays how do you view money and and
what is its purpose as far as your
concern well most of the money that I've
earned is now in our foundations mm-hmm
so I think I have only ten or fifteen
percent of the money that I've earned
that's not in the foundations but that's
plenty for me I enjoy being wealthy I
enjoy having my Bowden airplane two
houses one thing another there's no
question that I enjoyed but I also enjoy
the foundation and doing really
interesting things with the money as
we're doing with your telescope project
yeah that's very satisfying so I think I
like all aspects of money so yes yeah
certainly yeah it's uh they say god
bless the child who has his or her own
the question came in from a friend of
mine who was in the financial industry
so to speak and this person wanted to
know about kind of the philosophy by
which you run your life I guess I guess
I would say first question was do you
have a set of routines or habits that
that shape your daily activities do you
have you know space in your calendar for
just pondering things how do you
organize your daily schedule in terms of
your habits and and tactics when I was
70 I'm a smoker as you might have
noticed yes and at 70 I thought well
maybe I should give up smoking
now Marilyn suggested well maybe you
should take up excess
because that might help take your mind
off smoking hmm so I did that I got two
trainers and every morning I'd set my
alarm for six o'clock and 6:30 I was one
of with one of the two trainers Wow now
after a couple of months I went back to
smoking and I couldn't stand not smoking
but I loved doing exercise so I do that
every single morning well five days a
week
yes and I I do a walk very fast and then
I do push-ups and sit-ups and all that
kind of stuff hmm so that's a regular
part of my routine every morning for an
hour and the rest is totally
disorganized no it's you know I have
regular meetings with different people I
supervise at the foundation sometimes
it's a weekly meeting or a monthly
meeting but I that's the way I run
things but mostly of course as I told
you when you're high or wonderful people
you let them you know do that thing and
don't stand yes let me know I can find
someone to work out for me
that will actually do the exercise for
let me know if you can find someone to
do that one of my listeners friend of
mine who hosts a podcast himself James
all teacher wants to know the
proprietary algorithms of their of the
medallion oh he's he wants to know has
it become harder for you given the rise
in quantitative hedge funds quant funds
and the thousands of PhDs trying to
create new algorithms has that made it
harder to create alpha so can you say
what alpha means in the context of hedge
funds for people that aren't familiar
and then answered that particular
question well when you say alpha first
you have to understand beta hmm and beta
is the the stock market as a whole
let's say the S&P average so you could
just invest in that and you would be a
hundred percent beta all your return
would be would come from being let's say
the S&P the standard poor's
average alpha is a source of earnings
that is a THOG '''l to that hmm it's a
dog enough for them and so that's alpha
now some medallion fund is I think ie D
percent alpha ninety-five percent alpha
it really doesn't matter where the stock
market is going for the medallion fund
we have now the medallion fund is only
open to employees of the company of
Renaissance and me of course as a
founder and shareholder so and and we
have some publicly available funds which
you have some beta they're not a hundred
percent of course they don't do as well
as medallion but but they do well today
I'm sorry again I'm always here if you
need if you need a cup of sugar I'm here
so in that space the question is I've
heard it described that these super
computers and computers in general are
of course increasing exponentially
example of power computing power over
time and cost is coming down and yet the
supercomputers themselves are suffering
from the fact that there's more
subscriptions there's more people that
want to use the computer now than in the
earlier days so it's sort of offsetting
the exponential gains and processing
power and I guess James alterus question
here is has the just a net quantity of
hedge funds and quat PhD
yeah I didn't answer that question yeah
so I think the question is do we have
competition and how much competition has
competition hurt us at all because there
are more and more quantitative funds I'm
to a point I think most funds are not
quantitative funds but there's certainly
an increasing number of funds that are
quantitative and our secret is just to
stay ahead of everybody
mmm I are the best possible people and
the research goes on all the time all
the time or doing research trying to
find new predictive signals active
signals for example that's a big example
so a signal as well you know what a
signal I should tell you what's a
predictive signal is a signal that tells
you what's that what's going to happen
if some probability and stuff like with
a greater than probability greater than
1/2 mm and the more these signals that
you have and independent they're not
correlated with each other they're
highly correlated it's really good one
second but the more you have the better
and we have I won't even say the number
and I'm not sure what it is but it's a
very large number and they keep being
developed and sometimes these signals
lose their power yes you have to discard
them other people have caught on or
whatever in the earliest days of my
training I traded commodities and
pramana days had a tendency to trend
mm-hmm a pretty strong tendency to trend
so that was a good way to make money you
would just say well it was up last week
it's likely to be up next week so on but
people gradually caught on to trending
so after several years maybe 10 years
after I started
the trending in commodities had
completely disappeared
stocks never trended particular each
other was no real trendy charts but come
on rich there was and so so that's an
example of a signal just disappeared
hmm tonight on the show on the print
board
we don't keep discovering new signals
other people might find some of those as
well and that might the effect of that
might be but the signal kind of goes
away push to the new people using them
so we have awfully smart people and they
keep coming up with new signals so
that's and we've stayed you know who
stayed with ahead yeah so the last
section of the conversation I want to
talk to you about as befits the Father's
Day podcast episode that I hope this
will become really revolves around you
know the aspects of mentorship and
fatherhood and the first question I have
is what what was Jim Simon's like as a
PhD thesis advisor you mentioned that
you didn't have a great deal of students
in your career but what was your style
as a mentor to PhD students well
typically with the PhD student you have
to help them find a problem in
mathematics that you think that was
worth working on and so on and then
you'd be with him every week or
something like that and see how she how
he's getting along my first student it
was different my first student was when
I was I see how I was about 26 and I was
working actually at the Institute for
Defense analyses as a cold cracker I did
that for four years yep and and he had
just he had taken a course for me
Harvard he was again two years behind me
and then he went to Princeton and he
wanted to do differential geometry but
there was no one in Princeton at that
time who was especially good at it the
faculty didn't have that much so he
asked you know I could be his he could
be my student and I gave him some papers
to read and so on and then one day he
came in and he said I've proved
such-and-such
you prove such and such that's fantastic
and it was it got a great result that no
that result never occurred to me and but
he so he was my best student by far he's
won the beveling prize he's had a great
career his name is Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff
okay and so he was far away my best
others the others that I had I had
another pretty good one Bank John Olsen
but the rest were not especially good
and it was it was not so easy as I said
I only had maybe six and then on the
other side you know for somebody who's
seeking out a mentor or an advisor did
you have anyone will talk about your
father in just a second but did you have
anybody who was a mentor in the academic
world and the financial world or he just
really self-taught well I certainly had
some mentors is singer Tia singer index
Fay was a good person for me and this
was at MIT and so was his buddy
Lauren Ambrose he was an older guy did
geometry those two people were very
influential on me and it's kind of funny
because
we used to go to a delicatessen late at
night when I was a student and one day I
saw Ambrose and singer come in late at
night when they were obviously doing
mathematics and I saw this on a number
of occasions and I thought boy that's
that's the greatest job in the world
or you could just hang out and hang out
a delicatessen and do mathematics at
midnight so so those two people
influenced me when I got to Berkeley so
I spent one year as a graduate student
at MIT I graduated in three years I
spent one year as a graduate with singer
but he suggested I go to Berkeley and
work with churn who was just coming to
to Berkeley yeah so okay I got a nice
fellowship I went to Berkeley but we
Greta bleah
churn was celebrating his first year at
Berkeley by taking a sabbatical so he
wasn't there so I found someone else to
work with a guy named constant and he
influenced me quite a lot I like the way
he did things and there's a there were
various ways of doing geometry and there
was a statement from saying that
geometry is a subject that's invariant
under changes of notation there were
three completely different notational
things and turn like moving frames
whatever whatever that was a little bit
vector bundles and moving frames the
original thing was Christoffel symbol
for something and but covariant
differentiation was the way this guy
constant approached that and that's why
I've always approached it since and and
constant was
was a good guy I came to him one day and
said I have an idea and I showed him the
idea and he said oh that's that could be
related to this outstanding problem and
he told me the problem but he said but
don't try that because it's too hard
singer tried it Murrell the tried it so
that of course got me going yeah I
solved that problem and costomers was
pleased and surprised yeah do you think
if turn had been had been present at
Berkeley that perhaps your career might
have taken a different turn just
thinking serendipitously looking back
with the benefit of hindsight yeah it
could have been better but I was very
happy with the way it worked out yeah I
got the milk churn in my second year
there at Berkeley it was my last year it
was funny I was giving a seminar and the
beginning of my second year and this
tall Chinese guy walks in I said to the
guy that fit was that that's true
just the truth I had no idea he was
Chinese if his name was Chan Chan I
would have known I think he was some
Polish guy who changed his name from for
now Skeeter and I got to be friends of
course it was 25 years or 30 years older
than I am
yeah was but we became friends and and
he followed my work and I did some very
good work in what's called minimal
varieties a minimal variety of something
that minimizes surface area or a higher
dimensional area with respect to its
boundary
you know like if you put a wireframe
into a soap such a surface will form on
that wireframe and if it's twisted or
something it might look curious but it
has the least area of any other surface
with that same bound
that's called a minimal surface and that
was a very interesting field and I
worked in that for four five years and
produced a really good result a really
good job it's had it still got citations
after fifty years would still get
citations I thought I followed the
broken side your H indexes yeah so so
and turn he really ate that up he was he
wrote a whole set of notes on and I
thought wait a minute was he just
copying my he and I of course work
together
Symonds things right yeah I just I've
thought about that in your career you
know justjust in the context of you know
my adviser probably would never respect
me the same way that he would or you
know if I came to them as a fully
developed scientist whatever that means
just because they've seen me you know my
adviser Peter timbi has seen me at my
most ignorant and therefore I always
feel like there's no way he could ever
fully respect me the way somebody might
meet me after becoming more developed so
who knows maybe Shirin Simon's might not
have occurred if he hadn't taken that
sabbatical and then the world would look
very different at least yes I was just
going to segue a little bit into a
different type of mentorship which is
father-child mentorship so the first
question I want to ask you is there
anything about your father
any the the lesson or character trait
that he instilled with you I always
think of our parents job is to place a
little voice recording in the back of
our heads that we'll play at some time
in the future when we when we're not
around maybe is there any are there any
lessons that your father taught you that
you find yourself saying or thinking
even many years later yeah my father and
mother were very different
mm-hmm I was an only child my mother
after I was born she had some
miscarriages and then she had to have a
what's called a hysterectomy mm-hmm
whether the uterus is removed so she
couldn't have any more children so I was
for a project she didn't work of course
in those days mothers didn't didn't work
I was her project and she really was
tough on me that I get my homework and
so on and and I didn't so she cheated
she was she considered me her project my
father on the other hand she just simply
loved me for who I was whoever I was his
son he called me son me nothing he never
called me Jimmy problems and and he was
just a lovely man and it was just a
lovely may have and the only thing he
taught me and was he was a Salesman
he was a Salesman for 20th Century Fox
in fact in those days you'd go around to
movie theaters to try to sell them the
latest 20th Century Fox movie you know
rented for them so that was said he was
a Salesman and he would say to me
salesmanship is very important he
wouldn't frequently didn't you know how
it only attend salesmanship
but it turns out salesmanship is very
poor and you know it's it's good to be
able to sell something and even in even
in science you do some work and you want
other people to appreciate it and use it
and you know kind of solvent and but my
father was just a very very peaceable
man and I loved being with them together
on Saturday that was our day or Sunday I
don't know one of the two weekend days
that was our day together and he took me
to different places and just I saw I
really loved my father unfortunately he
got Alzheimer's at the age of about in
his mid 70s and he went downhill rapidly
so that was unfortunate no I did love my
mother don't get me wrong but she was a
tough customer yeah I always you know
say it's it's it's the toughest job and
and we have so much riding on it it's
one thing you know when one of our you
know kids was born I didn't know what
what to do and we were both actually is
our first child Isaac when he was born
and I just looked and I was in a stupor
and I said get the instruction manual
there's just no there's no there's no
instruction it's the hardest possible
job there is and and I wonder you know
how how you know it changes a person and
and it makes some people more mature
some people less mature but but in a
sense you can't be as selfish as you
were if you're a good dad I don't think
you can be as selfish as you might have
been even when you selected your your
spouse you know you're your partner you
can select a partner based on their
looks or their money or whatever and in
other words you can do it to fulfill a
need or selfishness that you may have
but having a child that's it's
completely the opposite I mean there's
no way they're they're gonna give you
anything except for a lot of sleepless
nights and then missed opportunities and
so forth at least for the first few
years my
I used to say I take an interest in a
child when he learns geometry you know
so hopefully you know we he got some
satisfaction of my nephew's who did no
geometry at a very young age before he
passed away
I want to talk a little bit about legacy
and maybe first what what becoming a
father meant to you and what it would
have taught you when you had when he
became a father you know for the first
time and and how did it affect you did
you did you have to make compromises in
your work and how did things change for
you change for me well I loved being a
father I was a very young father I was
22 when in those days that was not so
young but today 22 was for the young
your father yeah
my wife was 19 when she became mother I
loved it I loved being with my kids and
so have all kinds of adventures and so I
just really enjoyed being ya and you
obviously had a big role in my early
life when my father would go in on a
Saturday you know my parents were
divorced so he would bring me and my
older brother Kevin to the Stonybrook
math department and he would always say
something like and I don't know why I
kept working on me but he'd say come on
boys we're going to see we're going to
the amusement park with Uncle Jim and we
get there and he would you know he put
us in his office on one of the swivel
chairs and just that's the amusement
park that he and you would go off and do
some work on a chalkboard I thought this
is a pretty bum rap for ya for an
amusement music park but anyway you guys
had a lot of fun almost almost like
brothers themselves as I imagine we did
have a lot of fun well we were a
graduate school together yeah we both
finished in three years and he went to
Cornell and I went to MIT went to
Cornell and I went to MIT and we stayed
for
you know straight French yeah and and
then of course yeah I wouldn't have been
born at the Stonybrook if if you hadn't
been able to recruit him using all these
tools and tactics that my mom talks
about it subtle gentle manipulation
sending beach sand to Ithaca in the
middle of a frozen winter to get my mom
yeah yes you know he had a small boat
yeah you really like the water yeah it
was it was a good swimmer yes yeah it
was very athletic love to play tennis
and games and stuff and yeah I have very
fond memories of that time and my young
life it's a-you know it certainly is a
challenge growing up with parents that
are divorced but but I think you know
for that time period is very common back
then
I wonder thinking a little bit more now
about about your children and kind of
just greater lessons you once told me
that you want you want to live to be old
enough to see your great grandkids
because you remember your great
grandparents so that would be
essentially eight generations if I'm
doing the math they'll be connected with
Jim Simons in the middle so great
grandparents all the way to great
grandchildren and that made me think of
what you want to leave not as your
material will that's not important to me
in this conversation but what's known in
Hebrew as in Java ah it means ethical
will and it's sort of like what Alfred
sorry um when Alfred Nobel did with his
Nobel Prize he gave money away of course
but he also had a mission that the Nobel
Prizes be used to better mankind and I
wonder and that's sort of an ethical
will as well it's not just the material
riches that he had accumulated he had no
children no spouse but he wanted to give
away money to make a world a better
place but in your context we know what
you're doing in the foundation and
philanthropy around the world but I'm
more I'm concerned and questioning now
what would you like to leave as your
ethical will what values what whiz
would you leave for your
great-grandchildren great children you
know in other words a generation you're
not going to meet the ninth generation
so to speak your your great grandkids
children what values or even humanity as
a whole do you want people to to know I
guess
you know I don't go around thinking
about that question
I don't lecture my children I didn't
lecture them but I wanted to be a good
example to them and of course I wanted
them to love me as you know I've lost
two children terrible thing but the
children that I have I just I just hope
they they will remember me as a person
who accomplished a lot of things and
wish it but was a good father right you
know one counts up sometimes what has he
accomplished a lot of I accomplished and
well I'm pretty pleased with what I've
accomplished in science Oh Anthropy etc
pretty please
could be better but I think I I think
except for my smokey
make a pretty good example to people but
I don't dwell on that question on him
when I go down in history or whatever
although I think with all the physics
that turned Simon has produced I will
work on it for you yes that would be a I
mean it's even turned Simon's gravity
yeah as a possibility I think there's an
upper bound on what it could be but yeah
this church I was crowded in gravity
that was the most amazing thing that
happened in my life that this
mathematics that we did began to apply
to physics I didn't know any physics to
speak on people's I'm a so I didn't know
much physics and I just astounding you
know how many areas of physics this has
come to be so that's real surprise what
was that moment of discovery or
invention like for you I mean was it
slow in realization did you realize what
you had come upon or was it
collaborative and therefore a little bit
more paced slowly well at first I was
pleased with the mask I had started I
had gotten some results in three
dimensions which was very nice and and
then I showed it to turn and he said oh
we can do this on all dimensions we
can't yes I think they could so we did
and so that was that was that and I was
very happy with that and then Jeff
cheater
work together to invent something called
differential characters and that's been
useful but I think just in mathematics I
don't think differential characters have
been useful in physics but but Witten I
think with may be the first one to start
to start using turns on it but then some
Russians condensed matter physicists
also praying to me or we were using it
before
before what okay well that's great
but it's it's just it's one of those
things today you never know when a basic
science will go you just never go yes
and my favorite story is about IRA be
you know I of course yeah tomorrow yes
so he discovered nuclear magnetic
resonance it was a phenomenon he won the
Nobel Prize then several years later two
guys realized he could use it to analyze
materials they won the Nobel Prize and
then some years later after that two
guys one of them was at Stony Brook
realized we can make pictures they
didn't want to call it nuclear magnetic
resonance because nuclear frightens
people so they called it magnetic
resonance imaging MRI publicity all over
the place yeah so the story there is a
story and I don't know if it's right or
wrong about maybe that in his old age he
had some problem with his shoulder so we
had to go and was the father
zillions of machines so yeah I always
think about that story in context with
Alfred Nobel himself who suffered from
angina you know heart condition and was
later prescribed nitroglycerin too as an
ailment and that was of course a key
component in his most famous invention
of all time which was dynamite and we
used to remark on the irony the great
irony that he was treated with us and
they called it they used to call it you
know some healing potion or something
like that or trying nitrogen or
something and for the exact same reasons
that they changed MMR to MRI was for
publicity because seeing nitroglycerine
scared off the public into thinking it
was dangerous rather than therapeutic so
those two are connected in more ways
than one
the last two questions yeah yeah the
last two questions I have so one is
about the great distant future where
none of us will be around and I wonder
if you remember the movie 2001 a Space
Odyssey arthur c clarke based on his
book 2001 where these there are these
monoliths there are these structures
that appear in the African savannah
and then there's one on the moon and it
turns out these are objects placed by
alien civilizations deep in the ancient
past as sort of messages or warnings or
we're not really sure what they were
they're kind of ominous but also maybe
cautionary if you you have an asteroid
named after you you were one of the few
people I can say have an asteroid
although your lovely wife Marilyn also
has an asteroid named after so it does
you're too small that's sure yeah but
hers is faster really Charles is
delicately and and and swiftly about the
cosmos on your asteroid sixty six one
eight Jim Simons if you were to put a
monolith and it had to it was gonna last
for a billion years
what message or maybe an equation or
what would you put on it to signify
perhaps the achievements of mankind or
would you put a warning on it to you
know to a future civilization what would
you put on a monolith to last for a
billion-year time capsule on asteroid
66:18
well here's what I worry about in the
future so if you ask someone what do you
think that probability would be of a
nuclear holocaust in the next year and
he would probably say oh that's very
rare she won't give me a number so much
about me it one and a thousand one of
the count okay so that means if we've
gone 500 years there's a probability
greater than 1/2 that will have a
nuclear holocaust and blow the whole
thing up you know with the end of us
so I like to say that the most important
science is political science mm-hmm it
teaches us how to live together and I
say if we can't learn to live together
we're going to die and I really believe
we have to learn to live together so
maybe that would be inscribed next very
interesting they live together so the
very last thing that I ask all my guests
on the into the impossible podcast
relates to the name of the podcast into
the impossible I mentioned when I
emailed you to request this this
interview that arthur c clarke had many
laws the first one was any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from magic
his second law is for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert
there's a fourth law fifth law but his
third law is the limits of the possible
can only be defined by going beyond them
into the impossible and my question for
you is now we're gonna go back in time
what would you tell a 20 year old 30
year old Jim Simons what advice to your
former self would you give that maybe
seemed impossible at the time but then
you did it what advice would you give to
your
former self so I come out of nowhere and
address Jim once let's say when he's 24
yes he's shot so I show up I dress
myself cause he doesn't know who I am
what would I advise him mm-hmm well I
think it's very important to work and
enjoy your work so I would advise him to
find some work that he really enjoys and
work very hard at it that's very I can't
try it advice but I think it's good
advice for anybody I was young you want
to do something that find something that
you really like or better still go above
and then put your heart and soul into it
thank you Jim this has been a wonderful
conversation a happy Father's Day Jim
you've been a great force in my life we
talked about the greatest force in the
universe you've you've definitely in the
top very very selective set in my life
and in many people around the world
you've you've done so much for society
for basic knowledge in the pursuit of
wisdom for autism and now at the
Flatiron Institute working so hard on
issues of computational important I
think that's it's so commendable
thank you so much Jim for sharing your
time with me today in the podcast
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe comment
share rate and review for a chance to
win a free copy of our most recent
guests newest book send a screenshot of
your review to info at imagine UCSD edu
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to you suggestions for
future episodes for more information go
to imagination dot UCSD edu find us on
twitter and imagine UCSD watch us on
youtube listen on itunes into the
impossible is a production of the arthur
c-- clark center for human imagination
in the division of physical sciences at
the University of California San Diego
Eric veeery director Bryan Keating
co-director Patrick Coleman associate
director produced by Stewart volcko